erzählen ein eindrücklicher film den wir
gerade gesehen haben
verstorbene gegen lichtzeichen oder
erscheinen in träumen
wie geht das gibt es überhaupt ein
jenseits gibt es himmel hölle und
fegefeuer darüber diskutiere ich mit
dolly rutschte sie ist ein so genanntes
medium
sie hat einen draht in die geistige welt
verstorbene melden sich bei ihr und ich
diskutiere mit rebecca reformierte
theologie
sie hat viele sterbende begleitet und
steht für eine christliche spiritualität
ein so diese welt des jenseits in diesem
film wie nah ist ihnen die vertraut also
zumindest dann die geschichten sind wir
mal ganz unvertraut das was darüber
erzählt wird dass da auf dem grat
gewandert wird dass man die toten noch
sehen kann die unerlösten seelen
das ist etwas das habe ich ganz neu aus
diesen filmen gelernt habe ich
wunderschön gefunden von der art wie es
erzählt worden ist kenne ich nicht als
eine art was sich kenner ist im umgang
mit denen die sterbende und tote haben
dass sie so von erfahrungen berichten
diese nicht ganz klar
die für definieren können und sagen da
ist irgendetwas davon ist ja in wien
auch einiges zu hören und zu sehen
gewesen
ebenso wie so anrollen und habt wenn sie
sterbende begleiten
da sprechen wir leben vom moment des
sterbens vom moment des todes wahrlich
nicht von der zeit danach oder die dann
im film angesprochen ist manchmal ist es
aber so dass menschen die zum sterben
kommen dann anfangen zu erzählen sie
hätten verstorbene gesehen die sie
gerufen haben
insofern reden wir da auch vom jenseits
also da fängt es dann an dass es
irgendwie so geschichten gibt die mir
dann erzählt worden sind auch im sterben
ist diese welt er vertraut in diesem
sinne ist es mein tägliches punkt ich
bedarf diese seelen sehen spüren und
hören die welt danach vertraut in diesem
sinne ist sie mir nicht es ist ein
gefühl das ich kenne
was da noch leben gibt dass es nicht
ganz fertig ist mit dem abschied hier
mit dem ritual sondern dass danach doch
irgendwo das spürbar wie im film gezeigt
da sind doch noch welche das kenne ich
seit der kindheit zu ihrer arbeit kommen
wir mich interessiert noch ein zwei
themen aus dem film anzusprechen
dieser grad zurück zum beispiel ist das
ging recht schnell was ist das
eigentlich dieser grat zu versehen
also ich hatte schon von klein auf die
gelegenheit das wallis zu entdecken mit
meiner familie dort auch mittlerweilen
klein wo jetzt noch die leute in diesen
berg dürfen die sprechen viel über diese
grad züge die seelen banden die unerlöst
sind die müssen buße tun
man spüre die seelen dann nacht auf
diesen zügen man findet auch spuren und
man hat ja auch zu hause wie im film
eigentlich gezeigt wird schön
veranschaulicht das kenne ich diese
geschichten werden sehr oft in berg
welten nämlich nur im wallis sondern
eigentlich in vielen bergregionen
einander weiter 14 weitere zählt in der
kamin sie sind ja im emmental
aufgewachsen selber als auch eine
bergregion gibt es da eigentlich ja es
gibt da in dieser gegend da gibt es auch
so die die goldenen stellen ganz sicher
irgendwie man sagt die die golden werden
vergraben und man muss die suchen haben
auch viele danach gegraben weil es glück
bringen könnte und da geistern auch die
toten rum die unerlösten also es gibt da
auch in diesem sinne
solche geschichten aber nicht grad zug
geschichten weiß nicht wo sie genau in
deutschland aufgewachsen sind
wahrscheinlich nicht in den bergen
bemerken dass es typisch dass diese art
von volks gabe im bergregion halten
geblieben ist
ich würde mal vermuten dass es was mit
bergregionen zu tun hat aber ich würde
noch eher vermuten das hat was man
katholizismus zu tun denn die grad zug
geschichte wird ja eigentlich also wenn
ich es richtig verstanden habe erzählt
als die geschichte der unerlösten seelen
im fegefeuer sind insofern muss es ja
eine vorstellung geben von noch unerlöst
haid die überhaupt diese geschichten
produziert wie finden sie das als
reformierte also
als reformierte theologin wenn ich da so
eine eigene existenz davon habe finde es
ein bisschen seltsam
also mir vorzustellen dass es das gibt
gleichzeitig finde ich diese geschichten
sehr reizvoll weil sie werden die als
gruselgeschichten erzählt gern gesehen
die bälle so wie sie am feuer
miteinander singen und wirklich gruseln
geschichten erzählen und der große da
steckt ja da drin dass ich der nächste
mensch sein könnte dass stirbt und mir
kommt gar nicht so sehr darauf an dass
da die unerlösten seelen wandern sondern
dass die geschichte diesen kleinen
appell hat von denkst du daran dass du
der nächste mensch sein könntest das
stirbt also sie fragen ja danach wie
lebst denn du wirst du auch ein mensch
sein der dann mal irgendwann auf dem
grat zu passwörter nicht gut gelebt hat
und von daher finde ich die sympathische
geschichten also hat er noch was drin
steckt so hintze ambivalent ich habe
auch schon selber so geschichten gehört
seemann gestorben hat irgend eine blume
die sonst zu der jahreszeit nicht
geblüht wurde interpretiert als ein
zeichen
die person ist angekommen in salz gibt
im film viele beispiele
mike zb der berg führte gestorben ist
meldet sich über ein medium und hat dann
geschildert wie er seine beerdigung die
eigene erlebt hat sehr seltsam
das ist seltsam
ich erfahre dass meistens so dass die
verstorbenen die sich bei mir melden die
ich intensiv ii zieren darf sich
zurückmelden zum bestätigen ja ich hab
das mitgekriegt ich weiß was sie geplant
haben was ihr euch damit gedacht habt
und dass er auch an mich gedacht hat und
dass das okay es ist meist wurden
frieden bringen zum zeichen ich bin
angekommen
ob er diese fertigung toll gefunden habt
ob das alles genau richtig war und dass
geht es am ende nicht es geht darum ich
bin präsent also realität spuk oder
hamburg wie soll ich das eine ja so klar
ist dass man erst noch nicht
also ist die frage auf welcher ebene
seinen angaben auf einer persönlichen
ebene kann ich das zwar hören aber ich
kann das wenn ich jetzt mal auf meiner
persönlichen ebene bleibt kann ich es
erstmal nicht nachvollziehen
also ich selber mache solche erfahrungen
nicht ich höre dass von anderen menschen
ich höre von ihnen dass sie sagen dass
doch eine realität die melden sich bei
mir
bei mir hat sich noch kein toter
zurückgemeldet also ich erlebe dass man
erst nicht so das ist mal das eine das
zweite ist ich kenne ich kenne keine
notwendigkeit warum tote sich bei uns
zurückhalten sollten das ist also ist da
nicht steckt da nicht ein bisschen was
drin von dass wir die toten nicht tot
sein lassen können also dass es
irgendwie so eine verlängerung gibt über
den tod hinaus und so ein unbedingtes da
irgendwie noch einen kontakt haben
wollen sie sagen die melden sich bei uns
damit liegt bei denen dass es so einen
kontakt gibt ich habe bei menschen mit
denen ich kontakt hatte beim sterben oft
gemerkt wie schwer es ihnen fällt
wirklich loszulassen und es ist einfach
eine ganz schwierige arbeit das
loslassen das trauern das gehen lassen
und ich kann mir vorstellen dass auch
menschliche einbildungskraft die kraft
hat manche bilder zu produzieren
das muss doch dann aber noch nicht
gleich eine realität sein
im sinne von einer greifbarkeit ich
möchte gar nicht so weit gehen dass das
eine realität ist wie wie das jenseits
oder das paradies gestaltet sein können
was die menschen oder seelen dort tun
oder nicht tun
ich habe auch nichts dazu sagen ich kann
nur sagen dass ich die essenz des
gegangenen von hier aus diesen
körperlichen hier dasein gewechselt hat
und sich zurück melden möchte weil er
frieden bringen will
meistens geht es nicht um den toten
denen geht es ganz gut ich erfahre keine
und das widerspricht doch dem was im
film gesagt wird diese conny kabarett
sie zum beispiel eben auch ein medium
sagt sie wurde 21 jahre lang gedrängt
also ich finde es sehr aber ist sie
schon sehr positiv aber dass menschen
dann messen lesen lassen um von eben
verstorbene nicht mehr bedrängt zu
werden sich nicht zu helfen wissen
also es liegt ja vielleicht daran dass
diese schulung ich wurde damit gesegnet
am anfang war sein in einen fluch in
meinem leben dass ich sachen viele
menschen sehe die andere nicht sehen und
mir auszureden versucht worden sind ich
kann gar nie sehr gut verstehen wie sie
sich da äußert sie wusste nicht was sie
damit tun sollen die seelen wollten ja
nicht sie belästigen oder ihr
irgendwelche ängste in ihre ängste
auslösen hier ging es darum zu lernen zu
kommunizieren zu verstehen dass die heim
möchte ganz befreit sein möchten ins
licht
das immer nennen möchten das kann ich
auch nicht sagen wo der weg dann endet
und wohin es geht aber zurück kommen und
sagen meine frau geht es so schlecht sie
trauerte maßen
ich möchte dass sie weitergeht diese
gedanken nicht mehr hat es was ungelöst
ist wenn man das auflösen kann
mit einem gruß mir geht es gut ihr soll
es gut gehen
lasst diese gedanken dass seit ihr
verziehen was auch immer der friede ist
das ziel
dann gehen diese seelen dieselben die
plagen mich nicht wir klopfen nur an
und wenn man nicht weiß wie man damit
umgehen soll als ein ausschalten ohne
noch für sie auch sagt im film dann ist
das unangenehm
dann ist kommen wir mal zu der arbeit
die sie jetzt täglich machen
wie ging denn das dass sie gemerkt haben
ich hab da was ist anders bei mir bis
hin zu den dass sie das heute als medium
als beruf aus das hat angefangen im
kindesalter als meine eltern
festgestellt haben ja diese imaginäre
freunde haben alle kleinkinder ich hab
da mit sälen gesprochen mit meinem
urgroßvater der form einer zeit
gestorben ist
ich konnte denn dann auch beschreibenden
eltern spielerisch haben sie fragen
gestellt und so haben die festgesteckt
gestellt dass das das musste sony sie
man ihm gesagt hat ich konnte dann auch
als ich älter wurde sagen ja
der spielt gern karten der hudson das
gerne gemacht und mein großvater sein
vater sein sohn hat das mir dann auch
besteht die sowieso weißt du dass wir
das sagt er mir so viele sachen intern
in der familie offen nach außen zu ja
nicht sagen ja nichts das ist humbug
weißt du da musst du aufpassen so bin
ich dann richtung 20er gekommen wusste
nicht was ich damit tun soll was soll
das das ich diese leute sehen fühlte
mich auch irgendwie bedrängt wollte
normal seien natürlich in der nacht
menschen irgendwann doch geklopft hat
vielleicht nur in meinem kopf nicht
wirklich so musste ich ja hinhören
hinführen wer ist da was wollt ihr von
mir
die sind dann auch wieder gegangen wenn
ich das nicht zugelassen ich hab dann in
england diese ausbildungen gemacht auch
in der schweiz hat viele kurse belegt
gelernt diese sinne einzuschalten
auszuschalten
heilig vaters ziel in england
ausschalten normal sein ich will nichts
damit zu tun haben dass man mein ziel
und hatte ich dann da war das ganze
gesehen gehört die leute damit machen
diese medien kam der kleine gedanken
wann man könnte ich dann vielleicht noch
zum guten nutzen aber später und das
später kam dann nie es war dann einfach
da und ich wurde dann auch gesagt aus
dem umfeld du kannst du mal gucken ist
wie geht's dem wie geht es ihr sie hat
jemand verloren ihr geht nicht gut
kannst du da trösten sein und vielleicht
hält und so hat sich eigentlich mein
beruf ergeben ich habe ihn nicht gesucht
sie haben ja verschiedene berufe ausüben
kaufmännische berufe heute als medium
sie geben sitzungen wie läuft so etwas
ab als auch das sekretariat bucht mir
die sitzungen ich habe keine ahnung wer
kommt die spiele pro woche so bis zu 20
28 mehr liegt nicht drin familiär nicht
und auch energie
die menschen die kommen in unserer
gemeinschaftspraxis ich bin da der
paradiesvogel in diesem gebäude das eine
therapeutisch ausgerichtete praxis und
ich mache dieses medium da seien die
kommen ich begrüße ich will nichts
wissen ich frage nicht unterbinde auch
sehr schnell einig bin hier weil bitte
sagen sie nicht ich möchte ganz neutral
ohne irgendwelche inhalte anfangen zu
arbeiten zu hören wer kommt da kommt da
wer kommt da jemand kommen dann
vielleicht auch zweites ist ganz
unterschiedlich und die verstorbenen
sagen mir dann warum dieser mensch hier
sitzt was das thema ist das meistens
vielleicht abschied es kann auch sein
dass unerlösten aufgelöst
unausgesprochenes noch geklärt werden
kann so und dann gibt das frieden also
die menschen die zu ihnen kommen die
neuen bewusst mit verstorbenen kontakt
aufnehmen ganz klar hat es dann einen
therapeutischen effekt ich bin kein
therapeut ich kann ja nur vermitteln ich
bin die die dazwischen setzt hoffnung
schenken möchte mut machen also viele
kommen so rein und gehen aufgerichtet
wieder raus machen müssen die menschen
selber der freie wille der wurde und
auch geschenkt was sie mit diesen
informationen anfangen umsetzen können
das liegt nicht in meiner macht sie
hören intensiv zu was sagen sie da ist
das ein geschäftsmodell auf kosten der
verstorbenen wie sie sagen die man
besser ruhen lassen sollte es ist
zunächst mal etwas was menschen suchen
offensichtlich das lerne ich jetzt
gerade und sicher auch etwas was
deswegen auch ganz gut funktioniert und
sicher sind wir uns auch noch das große
deine sie zwar genau eine richtlinie die
das sagt zwischen 150 bis 200 franken in
der schweiz unter 150 gehobener
therapieansatz oder es ist keine
therapie
nein das haben sie ja das ist eine
einmalige sitzung es ist auch nicht ein
rollendes nutzung das möchte ich auch
gerne steuern ich also nein es entsteht
dann quasi eine beratungssituation indem
man etwas neues daraus lernen ich würde
erstmal sagen interessantes modell aber
die frage ist für mich wirklich immer
noch die würde ich das machen
beziehungsweise was steckt dahinter wenn
menschen das machen mich interessiert
wirklich wie kommen menschen dazu dass
sie das brauchen
und manchmal denke ich da hat unsere
religion auch zu wenig antworten gegeben
damit menschen mit diesen antworten auch
gut leben können
denn christlich religiöse reden wir ein
bisschen anders über den tod und sagen
von daher auch irgendwann ist dann da
eine grenze
also wir akzeptieren den tod als ein
sterben von allem also von körper geist
und seele und ein mensch ist tot wenn er
gestorben ist und kann da ist nichts
mehr da von ihm so und wenn nichts mehr
von den menschen da ist nämlich auch
nicht mehr kontakt zu ihm auf zumindest
nicht willentlich was nicht heißt dass
es nicht begeben begebenheiten gibt wo
ich nochmal träume oder nochmal wie
bilder auftauchen von einem menschen mit
dem ich was zu tun habe aber ich finde
es eigentlich eine erleichternde
vorstellung zu sagen
der tod ist das ende des lebens denn das
mahnt und so schickt uns ja recht
kräftig zurück zu der frage wie leben
wir denn eigentlich
und wenn wir jetzt diese grenze darauf
machen und sagen auch über den tod
hinaus kann man auch noch entwickeln und
beziehungen können auch noch über den
tod hinaus sich weiter entfalten und
wenn ich schuld auf mich geladen habe
dann mache ich das noch wieder gut wenn
ich mit dem totenrede dann finde ich das
schwierig weil es ging ja eigentlich mit
den lebenden und mein anspruch wäre mit
den lebenden so umzugehen dass es das
nicht braucht was nicht heißt dass es
schlimme situationen gibt also wenn
einer frau der sohn abstürzt und von
einer sekunde auf die andere nicht mehr
da ist das ist das ein schlimmer bruch
das verstehe ich sehr wohl aber ich
verstehe nicht was das für ein gehalt
haben soll mich dann dann noch mit ihm
zu unterhalten über die beerdigungen
genau
der schmerz ist doch der schmerz können
wir den nicht mehr aushalten
die aussage die beerdigung ist das
zentrum von so einem gespräch das eine
mutter zu meinem medium geht und mit dem
sohn in kontakt treten möchte dass das
das ist nicht so aber es kommt niemand
wegen einer beerdigung oder wegen den
richtigen blumen wie kommen eigentlich
mehr
meistens geht es ihnen gut und dann
kommt meine antwort ohne kontakt zu
haben zu einem verstorbenen dingen geht
es sowieso gut wir müssen gucken dass
wir hier uns gut fühlen diesen weg gehen
ich glaube dass das aufsuchen eines
mediums mehr eine vergewisserung ist da
gibts noch was ich spüre es ja noch okay
und der kommt dieser verstorbene sagt
noch mal hallo und richtig dass in
diesem sinne es war mein weg
ich verstehe du bist traurig und du
darfst es auch sein aber bitte lass mich
los
das ist ein wichtiger punkt loslassen
vergeben
raffin einziehen jetzt muss ich aber
doch mal kritisch nachfahren also wenn
sie haben gesagt die moderne
theologische positionen diese grenze der
tod den tod als grenze akzeptieren
lange war ja der kirche vor der
reformation da kommen sie gut war das
ein geschäftsmodell oder apps aus
jenseits also mit all den zahlungen die
man da geleistet denn auch ich bin etwas
anderes wissen für die phänomene die
falschen schildert gibt sehr viele
andere erklärung bis hin zu einbildung
wie würden sie denn was sonst noch
erklären also ich glaube ich glaube es
gibt im menschen wirklich auch noch das
bedürfnis danach so eine beziehung zu
haben zu einem menschen der gerade
gegangen ist und ich kenne aus meiner
erfahrung wirklich so stimmungen und
auch
im raum wenn ein mensch gestorben es wo
ich merke da gibt es irgendwie irgendwie
kommen wir dann ans nebulöse wenn wir an
unsere eigene grenze kommen und es gibt
im menschen glaube ich eine große
sehnsucht über diese grenze hinaus zu
gehen und zu sagen ich muss wissen was
danach ist es gibt einfach der tod ist
für uns glaube ich das größte ärgernis
was es gibt auf dieser welt also egal ob
wir ihm ausweichen die die moderne das
tut oder ob wir uns dem stellen ist ja
nicht so empörend wie die tatsache dass
wir sterben müssen
und es ist auch nicht so bedürftig wie
das suchen was ist denn da hinten tragen
wenn sie ja deswegen glaube ich machen
wir uns auch unsere modelle und
versuchen uns irgendwie zu erklären dass
könnten da noch sein schon in der bibel
suchen menschen und fragen wieso müssen
eigentlich die gerechten leiden und
sterben
und zwar vor allem den ungerechten das
ist schon immer eine frage also muss man
fragen was kann danach kommen und
versucht sich dann etwas zu entwickeln
und mein glaube viel mit gott zu tun und
mit der macht gottes und mit der
erzählung davon dass der tod vielleicht
wirklich nicht ganz das letzte wort ist
denn sonst wäre jesus nicht auferstanden
von den toten
also gibt es tatsächlich gott als den
der im tod da ist also kann ich sagen es
geschieht vielleicht eine verwandlung
das wäre das bild das die bibel hat gar
nicht eine erlösung von seelen und
sonstwas sondern eine verwandlung wenn
dann mal die auferstehung passiert und
dann kann ich die toten tot sein lassen
weil ich das abgebe und die macht gottes
das wäre für mich eine deutung und ich
glaube dass menschen heute je stärker je
länger je mehr nach einer erfahrung
suchen nach einem gespür suchen wo sie
sich ganz sicher sind und das ist glaube
ich stand der ort an den sie gehen und
sagen
spüren sie es wenn sie es für mich
spüren dann ist gut aber dann brauche
ich jemand das für mich spürt ich habe
mir mit den menschen die selber für sich
ihren weg gehen wollen als mit denen die
jemand anderen suchen
also ich hab mal einbildung oder
suggestionen jetzt im gespräch gebracht
sie haben jetzt auch die auferstehung
gebracht jetzt müsste ich mal in beiden
sagen
tut mir leid also wir können uns hier
nur mit unseren raum und zeit kategorien
unterhalten eigentlich wenn diese
kategorien nicht mehr greifen ist und
nach dem tod nach dem tod
darüber können wir uns eigentlich
sinnvoll nicht unterhalten müssen wir
jetzt aufhören
das ist doch sitzen
was sagen sie denn tradition wie
buddhistische tradition an kohl zum
beispiel in afrikanischen ländern in
asiatischen ländern tibetanische
totenbuch da wird genau beschrieben wie
man tote begleitet mal im sterben dann
die verstorbenen begleitung über 72
stunden nach dem tod ganz exakt welche
geräte welche schritte was soll ich dazu
sagen
ich sollte würde sagen ja gute andere
tradition nicht meiner
also man muss ja auch entscheiden in
welcher tradition man zu hause ist und
ich bin gerne in der christlichen
tradition zu hause in der seele und leib
einer einheit bilden und dementsprechend
auch alles tot ist wenn der mensch tut
ist das wirklich mal sehr sympathisches
nicht zu denken es gibt das wichtigere
was bei uns überlebt und das
unwichtigere was bei uns sterblich ist
nein
am ende dieses lebens geht alles in den
tod von uns und weil das so sympathisch
für mich ist bleibe ich auch bei regen
und wollte darf die auferstehung ja die
gott macht nichtig und da können
brauchen wir auch gar nicht darüber
reden was das dann genau bedeutet das
kann ich gar nicht wissen
da haben wir wollten noch über das
jenseits reden dass hier gibt es das
jenseits
für mich gibt es keines für mich gibt es
keines in denen irgendwelche zwischen
reiche oder irgendetwas sind es gibt das
leben das ist kurz genug es gibt die das
leben vor dem tod
dass es anspruchsvoll genug es gibt das
was wir da am grat zug noch gesehen
haben die erinnerung daran dass wir in
diesem leben gut leben müssen
es gibt den anspruch ein orden
anständiges leben zu führen und mit dem
tod ist das vorbei aber die abstimmung
hat dann mit dem jenseits nichts zu tun
die auferstehung ist das was gott
anverwandlung machen wird wo dann die
toten in der zwischenzeit tod bei gott
sind bevor sie verwandelt sind das finde
ich jetzt spekulationen darüber länger
während bei den raab zeitgeistigen er
genau ich mach mir da gedanken wie jetzt
gut leben da pflicht ich absolut bei so
leben dass wir jederzeit gehen könnten
alles aufgelöst erledigt ausgesprochen
und entschuldigt aber wenn der tod der
absolute tod von allen aspekten bedeutet
warum muss ich dann gut leben
warum muss ich dann nicht sein
wie ist denn das jedenfalls für sie ich
habe keine vorstellung es ist ein gefühl
ob es gibt 1 ich glaube ja ich fühle
mich da wenn ich verbunden bin mit
jemandem aus der anderen daseinsform
dann ist das sehr ein leichtes gefühl
und wenn man vielleicht meditativ tiefer
gehen kann und vielleicht mal kurz in
dieser essenz tauchen kann ob einbildung
oder nicht aber das ist wie eine liebe
es ist frei von allem leicht farbig bund
aber es ist nicht ein hauses ist nicht
ein grundstück zwischen baum
es ist nur ein sein ein gedanke man ist
nichts und trotzdem ist man wie im traum
man merkt man träumt aber man steuert
nicht
es ist ein gefühl ich kann nicht sagen
die kommen ich brauche auch nicht ich
frag geht es dir gut die erzählen von
sich wie sie vielleicht den übergang
erlebt haben wie schwer war wie leicht
ist sich angefühlt hat schlussendlich je
nach situation hat aber die kommen nicht
und sagen hier ist es nicht schön ich
fühle mich wohl
die kommen nicht und ich frage auch
nicht wie sieht denn bei euch aus das
was tut ihr das ist gar nicht im zentrum
sie beschreiben sich so dass sie
erkennbar werden dass das die mama ist
von diesem herrn der hier setzt und dann
ist das für mich nur eine energie es ist
nicht gewesen
es ist das was mal war in eine
erinnerung aber aus etwas finde ich es
ist eine auferstehung jesus christus kam
ja auch zurück und hat sich seinen
jungen aposteln gezeigt wie finden in
allen religionen diese wieder
erscheinungen auferstehung warum soll
uns reims unser einfaches volk warum
sollten wir das nicht auch so erfahren
und uns so ergehen dürfen wurden sieht
er jetzt gerade auf einen widerspruch
aufmerksam gemacht in der bibel neues
testament auferstehungs erscheinung so
christoph theologisch geschult ich kann
da nur auf meine kindheit - verstanden
aber der einzige der erscheint also von
daher zeigt sich an ihm
wie überhaupt auferstehung also dass es
auch verstehen gibt dass darin zeigt
sich sozusagen das gotten tod begrenzt
heißt aber nicht dass danach alle
anderen auch verstehen und auch schon
mal zeigen so wird es sein sondern
daraus gründet sich der glaube es könnte
sein dass gott wirklich alle menschen am
ende der zeit verwandelt die toten wie
die lebenden so etwas neuem kommen
deswegen streiten das jahr im neuen
testament
was passiert eigentlich mit dem leben
wenn man das ende der zeiten vorher
passiert müssen alle sterben damit sie
verwandelt werden können das vielleicht
auch nicht aber ein passiert eine
umfassende verwandlung das ist das ende
aber was wir nicht kennen und das hat
auch gar nichts mit
mit volk und den einfachen menschen zu
tun was wir nicht kennen oder was ich
fremd findet aufgrund meines
christlichen glaubens ist das einfach
dass alle auferstehen nachdem sie
gestorben sind sie erzählen dass in
wunderbaren erlösung und paradies
kategorien das was sie jenseits nennen
also in filmen kenne ich die bilder oder
dass die atmosphäre die sie beschreiben
und das ist das was erlösung was das
endete zeiten was sie lieben weil sie
sagt da wird es irgendwann mal sein also
auch bei dem bild sind wir uns dann
vielleicht sogar nach was ich nicht
glaube ist dass das ganze ohne die macht
gottes geht und die erzählung an der ich
vertraue heißt so wie gott den einen
auferweckt hat wird am ende der zeiten
alle an
vorweg sie nicken aber ihre tradition
ist ja nicht christlich ich bin getauft
und schließlich referieren bezogen war
vielleicht schon damals dass unliebsame
kind das fragte wo das andere soll her
kommt von kain und abel sich dann
irgendwie doch hinter gehen also ich und
dann hieß es das war damals ist schon
solche fragen stellt man nicht okay
schon ketzerisch genug in dieser zeit
ich habe vieles nicht aus böser absicht
hinterfragt nie ich wollte verstehen
ich würde da was was andere nicht so
deutlich war es gab ja im 19 jahrhundert
und bis heute die tradition des
buddhismus also wo man sich auch
vielleicht spielerische form davon dann
getroffen hat hier eine aufnahme aus dem
jahr 1870 als frankreich um zum beispiel
tische zu rücken also tische die sich
dann eben ohne menschliches zutun bewegt
haben wir haben hier ein beispiel das
ist was anderes ist das ganze ja nein
spiritismus hat mit ansicht meines wie
die tourismus es nichts zu tun also dass
es um den kontakt mit ordnung ist sie
wahrscheinlich schlussendlich denn die
essenz dass man zusammenkommt und
irgendwie versucht das glaubwürdiges
herbeizuzaubern das geht es für mich
schon in richtung magie und beschwörung
und ich kann nicht mit dem nicht
identifizieren das ist nicht sinn und
zweck dass man einen tisch werden lassen
kann
zum beweisen dass es geister gibt weil
da habe ich eher das gefühl dass wir
möglichkeiten haben mit unserer mentalen
kräften energetisch was in bewegung zu
setzen oder sich mental dieser
kugelschreiber sich bewegen könnte
glaube ich an so an dass das ist sind
wir aber da hat das hat nichts mit den
verstorbenen und ihre tradition meine
tradition erst ich bin schließlich
bleibe christlich ziehe meine kinder
christlichen glauben
ich wende mich nicht eine kirche zu oder
eine kirche ab ich bin sie am
spiritismus genommen oder das ist der
ansatz dass der glaube dass das leben
nicht fertig ist mit dem tod
das dass es weitergeht dass es ein leben
danach gibt verstorbene namens daniel
kontakt da genau schildern doch auch wo
sie sehen wie sie ihm geht wie gesagt
wie ich habe noch nie
beschreibungen von örtlichkeiten oder es
ist nur dass sein designs nur weil sie
gerade so interessierte ob es jetzt ein
gericht gibt oder ein feuer oder eine
ruhig aber ich glaube nicht an
ich glaube nicht daran dass jetzt petrus
wie man so einen volksmund sagt amthor
städten sagt so liebe herr soundso der
liebe dame iks das hast du und gut und
das hast du schlecht getan das war dann
glaube ich nicht aber ich glaube daran
dass die seele ein kammer hat und dass
das kramer 1 soll und haben konto ist
nehmen wir einen bankkonto mit sohn und
haben das leben fühlt sich da das gute
wie das nicht so gute und dass die seele
wenn sie drüben erwarten weiter gehen
möchte
selbst diese waagschale hat sieht und
weiß was das ich noch nicht dass
lichtvolle ganze bin vielleicht wie das
göttliche licht dass da noch was übrig
geblieben ist es noch nicht ganz
vollendet er in der buddhistischen
tradition vorkommt in verbindung mit dem
relegations gedanken dass die menschen
mehr seiner verantwortlichen dass wir
das vor augen geführt gegen diese bilanz
ziehen aber wissen wir sind jetzt auf
dieser seite des seins form und ich mir
hier aber in bei gericht und fortuna hat
bekommen es ist ja nicht dass jemand
kommt und uns verurteilt als schlächter
seele oder sünder sondern ich glaube
daran dass die seele
sens mit dem großen ganzen immer
verbunden ist und es gibt einen weiteren
ganz weiß und vielleicht ist dann jemand
noch nicht ganz ohne gericht
also ich habe bei dem gericht schon ein
bisschen hühnerhaut das liegt aber
glaube ich vor allem an den ganzen
vielen bildern die einem dazu dann
sofort kommen von mittelalterlichen draw
bildern wie schlimm das alles wird und
dass eben dass man solange unerlöst sein
muss und wie viele jahrzehnte und
jahrhunderte man im fegefeuer steckt
weil man irgendwas schlimmes getan hat
und natürlich nicht nur sünde hat die
letztlich wäre die man abarbeiten könnte
sondern überhaupt durch das menschsein
schon so sündig dass man erst mal noch
lange büßen muss grundsätzlich
allerdings ist es ja so sie habe ich
vorhin gefragt warum sollte ich dann
lohnen gut zu leben wenn nach dem tode
alles aus ist erstmal glaube ich leb mit
gott und gott ist nicht ganz klar ob ich
gut oder schlecht lebe und mich
beteiligen an der besserung der welt und
an gerechtigkeit auf der erde oder nicht
von daher entsteht dass durch meine
gottesbeziehung schon mal da habe ich
aber schon auch daran dass es zumindest
meine hoffnung die hat jesus so auch
gehabt dass es nicht egal ist ob es
gerechtigkeit gibt oder nicht und dass
es gott auch nicht egal ist und dass es
gott auch im universalen sinn nicht egal
ist
das heißt dass es bei keinem einzelnen
menschen und auch am ende der zeiten
nicht so ganz egal sein wird ob gut oder
schlecht gelebt ist aber nicht im sinne
von einem verurteilenden gericht wir
glauben ja dass gott uns auch liebt okay
aber als loser alsdorf taucht gerichts
gedanke sagt ihnen was aber sie
vertreten klar eine moderne theologische
ansicht wie sie in 20
jahrhundertjahrgang gelb ist entsteht
das eben die christliche theologie sagt
wir reden nicht über ein jenseits und
wir sprechen einig über die wirkung wenn
sowas gibt den jetzigen leben packen
wir's an die differenzen zwischen ihnen
sind klar geworden ist es so der punkt
wo sie sich zum schluss unseres
gesprächs
wo sie sich treffen würden hier jetzt
gilt wenn wir uns hier treffen mir ist
es recht
absolut ich gehe davon aus dass wir uns
wieder treffen
irgendwo ich glaube da haben und ich
möchte auch diesen glauben behalten für
mich zu wissen
dort drüben wo immer das ist oben unten
rechts links oder genau hier
es wird ein wiedergeben ein wieder
zusammenkommen gehen in eine andere
science form dass ich habe nach dem
punkt der ermutigung benzin und den habe
ich noch gemeint also dass die menschen
die zu ihnen kommen dann gestärkt aus
einer sitzung rausgehen habe ich bei ihm
jetzt raus gehört also nicht wie beim
gericht das damals jetzt was bedeutet
das für das jetzige leben ist dass der
bund muss scheint hinter st
nach einem gespräch über das jenseits zu
landen das ist doch gesund auch das
kommt jetzt erzählen dank für das
gespräch
wir bleiben beim thema und bei einem der
sich zeitlebens mit dem tod und den
menschlichen abgründen beschäftigt hat
den künstler und maler hr giger eine
hommage jetzt in der sternstunde kunst
ihnen einen schönen sonntag